let's play a quick roundup
or dare
every time
all right so i actually do if you don't
mind i'd like to switch it up a little
bit today if you don't mind i dare you
drew i'm gonna dare you to surprise a
member of our audience here who's a big
fan of the show
okay well i did hear about a todd
weinstein
he is in the audience look at look at
he's just looking over there
are you surprised
[Laughter]
come on down come on right down here
todd everyone
surprise
wow well hi are you surprised
like
speechless i like this speechless wow
wow
well well um so your wife wrote in and
uh she told us that you are getting
ready to start a canned food drive for
your 50th
birthday
will you tell us about it
oh i stopped crying
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i am so inspired by your story i was
wondering like how did you get the idea
for it well i work with this food pantry
on long island and i run a community
group called nice things that happen in
east meadow it's a big shout out so it's
really about community goodness where we
live what you're doing really speaks to
me it inspires me and it's like who i
really want to be and who i'm trying to
be and
um we know that the inn is a charity
very near and dear to your heart is that
correct oh yeah yeah okay well we're
gonna donate a thousand dollars to them
and
of course i'm gonna match it so that's
another thousand dollars so we'd like to
donate two thousand dollars
and then would it be okay to put your
organization up on our website and drive
traffic to it so that we can keep
supporting we're a closed group
gotta gotta live in our town that's it
we don't want i mean you could become
our friend but no outsiders
by the way i love it no the answer is no
no well we do want to support you
yeah and we won't say anything negative
wow
absolutely
thank you i would love to what is it
called again nice things that happen in
east meadow
i mean nice things that happen east
meadow can i please promote you on our
website well then you got you got to do
me a favor then okay yeah so i'm turning
i'm turning 50 in june
and uh
i wanted to do you know you know parties
and stuff and you know craziness but i
wanted to do like a canned food driving
i wanted to collect
1972 cans of food for our food pantry
and that's what i was going to announce
i would love to have a little video of
drew barrymore giving us like
introducing this food drive on our page
we can we can do i actually know drew
barrymore i know
i could make that happen and if you'll
have me i would love to do this
i really would well if you don't mind
i'll make you that video today and
fantastic maybe we could be members of
your facebook group even though we don't
live in the area we know we're you're
welcome welcome to visit our town we'll
be nice i promise
thank you for inspiring us with what
you're doing and uh choosing to
celebrate your 50th birthday you've
inspired us thank you thank you very
much
thank you todd i'm gonna make you that
video thank you so much
[Music]